على مدار الشهرين المقبلين ، سيسافر حوالي
90.000 مشارك أولمبي من أكثر من
200 دولة إلى طوكيو ، مما
فتح أبوابها فجأة
لدولة أغلقت حدودها
بسبب معظم حالات الوباء التي تطمح إلى انتشار
19 حالة في اليابان
وأجزاء كبيرة من اليابان.  البلد
في حالة طوارئ
، ستضيف الألعاب الأولمبية عبئًا آخر
على النظام الصحي الذي هو بالفعل
أكثر من طاقته
على عكس رمز الوحدة
والسلام والأمل ، وأصبحت الألعاب الأولمبية
كابوسًا لحدث السوبر سوبر في
طوكيو حوالي 2 من  تم تطعيم 126 مليون شخص في اليابان
بشكل كامل ، وقد
تباطأت عملية الطرح بسبب البيروقراطية
ونقص الطاقم الطبي
لإدارتهم بالمعدل الحالي ،
ولن يكون باقي السكان البالغين
مؤهلين حتى للحصول على اللقاح بحلول الوقت الذي
تبدأ فيه الألعاب الأولمبية حسب
ادعاء المنظمين  ستقام الألعاب
في فقاعة آمنة في هذه القرية
الأولمبية وسيتم اختبار الرياضيين يوميًا
ومراقبتهم من خلال تتبع الاتصال
لقاحات التطبيقات ليست مطلوبة ، لكن المسؤولين
يقولون إن أكثر من 80 في المائة من القرية الأولمبية
سيُطلب منهم ممارسة
ارتداء أقنعة التباعد الاجتماعي باستثناء أوقات
التدريب والمنافسة
واستخدام وسائل النقل العام فقط عند
الضرورة
الآن يقول الخبراء على الرغم من أنه من
المستحيل  حافظ على الألعاب الضخمة
آمنة تمامًا بالإضافة إلى أنهم يقولون إن هناك الكثير من
الطرق لثقب هذه الفقاعة
حيث يتواصل المشاركون في الأولمبياد
مع
عشرات الآلاف من المتطوعين غير الملقحين
الذين يعيشون خارج
أماكن الألعاب الأولمبية الفقاعية في جميع أنحاء طوكيو مع
سباق الماراثون والبعض  أقيمت مباريات كرة القدم على
بعد 500 ميل شمالًا في سابورو ، لذا
فمن مسؤوليتها الحفاظ على سلامة جميع
المشاركين في الأولمبياد ، يضع كتاب اللعب الأولمبي
المسؤولية النهائية على عاتق
الرياضيين
بدلاً من المنظمين أو أن الحكومة
اليابانية تنفق أكثر من 15 مليار
دولار على هذه الألعاب
دورة الالعاب الاولمبية الصيفية باهظة الثمن مسجلة
بما في ذلك 900 مليون دولار في Co
الإجراءات المضادة البيطرية
لكن استطلاعًا تلو الآخر أظهر أن
الغالبية في اليابان لا تريد إقامة هذه
الألعاب ،
بالتأكيد لا أعتقد أن اليابان يجب أن تمضي
قدمًا في الألعاب الأولمبية ،
أنا خائف جدًا ، يعتقد الجميع أنه
لا ينبغي لنا إقامة الألعاب الأولمبية
ولكن الحكومة ليست كذلك  في وضع يسمح
لك بالقول إنه في النهاية لا يعود الأمر إلى حد كبير
إلى كتابة العقود الأولمبية
اليابانية لصالح اللجنة الأولمبية الدولية ، لذا فإن المعارضة العامة
للنظام الطبي الذي يتجه نحو الانهيار ،
وتجاوزات التكاليف
، كلها أعباء سيتعين على طوكيو أن
تتحملها لديها السلطة
القانونية لإلغاء  دورة الالعاب الاولمبية لكنهم يخططون
لحرث سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن طوكيو